it's pretty brilliant it's pretty
amazing but you know amazing thing is
that like honestly no matter what clear
razor them yeah you want to think of you
can find validation online of course you
can it's called confirmation quite a big
problem yeah a huge problem
you know people usually approach the
world they have a feeling about
something yeah and then what they do is
they'll go and cherry pick data to that
app or that feeling that's what we all
miss but what like it run little too
it's what makes the internet also that
it's a huge liability oh yeah but I can
go because I can say something like
people in dumped Dublin or twice smart
as Americans no they're not Google it
bro yeah and then Google and you're
going to find it somewhere matter
Nashville dark and laugh they some [ __ ]
said it if you if you you're googling
the question that you like by Google if
I wanted cigarettes to be healthy for me
don't you find it I could Google but I
could ask Google the question that gave
me the right answer well here's the
other so my friend has cancer right so
I've had a lot of people reach out to me
and give me all kinds of like
alternative therapies and also people
who are Mavericks who are curing cancer
on the side problem is that when you
hear about these people who are these
heroes it's very interesting because
they're curing the you know a lot of
people come to their clinics and stuff
the data is it's very very wishy-washy
and if you actually do some research you
start to realize that they are usually
being investigated by different medical
boards and people and they're being
debunked now what happens though is that
those people then say look at how Big
Pharma and the industry is trying to
censor me and putting that hole right
and so they actually turn that to their
advantage so now if you believe that all
of the medical industry and all of Big
Pharma is corrupt if you're one of those
people out there it's all about money
and they could cure cancer but it's all
about making money if you actually
believe that which is I think a little
bit absurd if you look at the deep the
data but but if you were to believe that
you can 100% make a case for it well do
you end up like Andy Kaufman elephant
Africa and the guys doing the weird
stuff yes so it's not some alternative
therapies I'm sure don't have merit it's
that it's very easy to kind of say AHA
I'm being indicted or I'm being
investigated or I'm being censored there
for that means that I'm a threat to the
mainstream and that's why I wish I
GoFundMe for our cancer reason which I
give them adieu we have our own research
on this I'm glad there's a segue behind
you running this up yeah really ever
doing some research well yeah my buddy
we did this thing but we did it go fund
me for my buddy and also we get a stand
of thing and probably ready we raised
you know if I raised about 55 grand my
buddy goes that's awesome thank you so
much ain't gonna do [ __ ] for the
research obviously yes there's a lot
more we love about 55 billion yeah
$55,000 and the research continues but
the you know it's crazy and this is why
conspiracy theorists make me laugh
because everyone started the podcast yes
they're given a man-child should we do
an intro great Freddie Prinze jr. Josh
whoa too much they do my face maybe your
podcast prints in the wolf prints and
every week we share an agent and when
they told me you and play we're getting
together went brilliant yeah perfect we
you I read I had to wrestle the artwork
guy out of you you were like this and
don't pass this dude's name along please
make no trying to copy my job Android
stuff way too many people dust-up with
that artwork yeah fantastic yeah some of
them you know like when an impression is
so good that you can't hear it because
it's creepy sounds like they ate the
person that they're doing it yeah some
of the artwork was so good that was like
that looks creepy I can't look at it
yeah people literally would like respond
like I can't stop looking at it but I
can't look at it yeah yeah it's nice and
creepy and weird that masking it to me
that artworks huge man yeah it's huge
you see so many people doing it now
trying to recreate it because you know
you're mark you're basically marking
your show and so people they don't put
any time into nothing like that and it
makes the world of difference there's so
many podcasts out there that if you're
gonna that's like kind of your first
impression yes and but there's that
guy's where something guys just sweet
there's a podcast though I was just at a
club and I'm not gonna put this dude on
blast I was at a club where the door guy
the comedy club was like a maybe what do
I do my podcast after the show and I was
like
now I'd like you know who's listening to
it he's like well the staff really likes
it I'm like well they can listen to my
act
well that's that's like Amy Schumer fake
how did you name me humor major I mean
she she goes ah like the cheese cheese
in her staff meeting with all the
writers and then she's like any comments
concerns and some guy goes yeah I do you
have time to do my part I don't have
time to goddamn pockets who else has
upon guess the o-rings okay just no more
podcast in here
no one's do any more projects barelli's
everyone has a lot of Star Wars cartoon
and that on Twitter like every third
tweet I get is hey man you would do my
Star Wars forecast I was like bro I did
like five the first season they had
you know like know if like you know a
couple hundred followers come just to
like be nice and then once people found
out I was doing those I was like oh
never a jerk cause it's like you know if
no no but I'm trying to be a nice guy
have your own show so if you want to
talk about it find it there yeah you
were video like I asked where you want
to release your information yeah I feel
good I'll do my friends podcasts or of
these certain interviews but if I'm
gonna like drop some [ __ ] it's coming in
here and we're you acknowledge me off
and you drop analogy we stop in the
knowledge you have all the knowledge but
I do make all our repository my brain if
you could see my plight that your voice
gets leaked about knowledge bring it
down a little pan scrape a little I like
to squint a little squint I just I just
want to kiss knowledge can be scary
sometimes and I'm trying to criticize I
understand now I'm gonna stay whatever
tone right I do want to say before you
walked in that Brendan was saying that
my chest was a little more manly than
yours I'm saying he has the best body
comedy I'm sorry
and so I just wanted to make sure you
have heard that first you sell out
Dublin in Ireland that quick and I know
he did UK and then you got to talk about
his body will this [ __ ] I'm Brian today
you guys you have a pot off what's the
wicked on [ __ ] now that I'm doing
more incline bench now so get ready for
my okay either way
well he's so been doing right I do I
went bought Inc no no no before you got
before you got here tell already
Brendon literally said I just got to get
him to do some meat pie because I don't
have in there you go I don't want him to
have the bird cage he's like yeah he
goes I'll buy it for him I just want him
to do some marijuana and you open the
door like five minutes look nice forever
I went on Amazon still he because you
just got to get the shove or incline
loser
50 year old Amazon bench I'll get the
better one
not even the better one yeah cuz you
know in case it breaks down I put it
together myself which is incredible I
can't do anything like that listen I
bought the way and now I do I do in fact
today I swear guys I walk in the pockets
I go I'm gonna do incline today right so
you see it all right I'm sure I'm not
sure so I don't put on muscle I just
don't I'm an ectomorph all right well
then you guys this the bones will get
bigger though the bull you'll be like an
exoskeleton I've got a little bit of ego
yeah you could have the best exoskeleton
in comedy is that what is that what is
that what we're going for did grow it to
grow our skeletons well he said that's
all the growth that's a maggot look like
a weight above it's funny that redditor
we come from a generation where we're
always going to be in shape all of us I
think right we all hold onto our vanity
but like my father's generation if you
look at them they just simply oh let
themselves go [ __ ] it generation the
different cuz obesity has never been
well that's true but that might be
that's true actually because you're
living in a calorie you're in LA and
we're Litella for dreams have never been
there's just a whole lot more extremes
now right well they're they're people
who are in incredible shape but also the
extreme on the other end of never see my
six own pound life have you ever been to
Walmart anywhere in the south go to
Jess's right like Rob Lowe and I'm like
I'm gonna hang out everybody crawl below
he looks pretty good
Logan but our Americans in better shape
wouldn't you say CrossFit it's a legit
subculture and you know it's a small
subculture I guess you live in this
modern world man like this weird small
world close to me so I see a lot of in
shape people yam I had a lot of guys on
TRT and a lot of women to do yoga so
they look great but we can go to
Palmdale if you want to the inland I
think that it hasn't so you think
probably Americans are not in for the
fattest country in the world so what
that has made us more health like the
pro wrestler the big show he's lost 100
pounds man Bryan how much do you a sick
son around bro he was like honey 490 and
that was like for Honda you tell them
but uh yeah dude look Google a picture
he's like felt legit in big show Bryan
I'm telling God he looks happy because
it is and stuff probably yeah I cannot
where I'm not super buff because I don't
want to hurt bloody parts of our country
that are not down with like I was in New
Orleans oh my god
look at my man look how much weight he
lost that sang-soo day oh that ain't no
CGI son yeah that is my hood man yeah
he's all the bagged a couple a hat on
that road keep your big ass away from
juice de if he touches our pizzas he I'm
gonna do nothing he'll bring that chop
on Geneva China his big ass at Shaq holy
[ __ ] he's huge oh dude we're actually
has the giantism gene Oh does your tires
are low your oh yeah oh he's as big as
Shaq no that's my boys name is Pauly
ever in whoever doesn't next to somebody
that big not so much you because you're
all sort of things like oh I am that
awesome you know real like basketball
play like what yeah but you're closer
with a jacket inches I'm a foot
yeah and I'm six one and I'm how many
pearls over your waist when you stand
next to those people you're like aren't
we the same blood same species now like
you have another picture like this
like if I could jump shot great games
I'm fronting me on man
go to your post move it's not I want to
feel that again go to your post there's
some people you mean really like we're
not the same species but I don't play
basketball word we're not the same so
tonight the room I realized what NFL
football players were like Justin Tuck
and Alden Smith at a wedding and they
were they were flanking you and I always
look to you as a huge guy and they were
just much bigger than you
what's incredible didn't know this at
the Gracie Academy I think was last
summer the summer before
Trent Williams from the Washington red
hands was there big dude six seventy six
eight so his little brother's there too
I don't know that it's his little
brother and I'm talking to him and I see
him rolling he's like yeah you know I'm
thinking about where I'm gonna play and
I'm like oh yeah like you a free agent
what's going on and he goes no what what
college that I'm gonna go to I said what
what how how old are you boys like I'm
17
oh my god he's 300 plus and he's not fat
yeah my dude I was like dude what Oh
laughs and I'm standing next to like
both these guys in between the point did
you see hunters video on it was oh yeah
that basketball kids every teen mm is he
16 7-eleven brain he's everywhere I got
yolk down about 15 you want to challenge
Hannah
he doesn't know juicing challenge Hannah
to see what sweet challenge tenner and
Brian Ortega you know ranked number 10
or 8 and you'll see yeah that was bad is
yeah yeah and you know you get it
handling like this weird headlock and
Heather like just pops out of it and
then give him the doors choked guys like
what the [ __ ] I won't go you're serious
you thought like you is gonna go in
there when you were 16 years old you
felt indestructible a bad idea okay we
also hear out not being was like the
humbler except at 175 your once yeah see
that's the crazy thing now I remember
like maybe on my high school football
team there was one legitimate maybe one
legitimate athlete in one legitimate big
person do you mean yeah but now you look
at these my son was in Notre Dame in the
valley and the teams that were playing
it's like everybody all those offensive
linemen across the border over 250 oh
they'll recruit
recruiting though I don't like then this
Hester has that little more big people
there recruiting and MOA we're a private
party I'm here no that's I went to uh
when my friends kids games and they're
playing this inner-city team and they're
like beating the hell out of them and
they go I go oh yes I'm game neck
because I love watching football high
school football me too I go older game
next week I'll go she goes there is but
we won't be at it I'm like why not she
goes we play and I'm free to this
powerhouse she goes last year they beat
us 85 two zeros last there she goes and
a lot of players got injured and we
don't have a lot of guys so we're just
going to skip the can I go no tip
dangerous yeah it's actually bad for the
health but we're not with literally not
John oh we got a football team by the
way they're gonna play T son she killed
me oh I know the team pull out they're
like wow we're good speaker watching it
next week ya know no one's gonna get
just no social mm-hmm should have a last
year we heard they have a running back
he used to play both ways but he okay to
do and a half to 25 okay he used to play
both sides because he could play live by
he hurts guys on defense on average
every third place I saw a receiver and I
look like Calvin Johnson I'm like yeah
just do you guys just haven't run
straight and I stood the ball and
they're like that's exact that you do
fix we're looking for quarterbacking in
sort format and he did it like this once
yeah - hmm so nothing to that early
college so far you guys did blank are
you Division one college like right
everyone's like that so let's go do this
yeah you'll get tackled a real clue yeah
real Italy Rafael and I'll pop you in
your change will be like what where's my
route wells like weird you guys are for
Finn I look at the corner banks is
little 510 white dude hunter Canada my
three majors that is 60 minutes did a
thing on Samoa and all the football
players come out of there yeah and they
say they were looking at just their bone
structure and said you if you are Samoan
versus someone who is of European
ancestry you have a 55 times more of a
chance
more likely that you would be able to
plan the NFL then would the absolute
also turn a person yes as well
genetically like it's like this guy my
friend hired his body guard and he shows
up and he's too smug I got tried to step
into our area and it was in the strip
club and the guy with him grabbed the
guys but turn around and grab him by his
hand and went whoa my man
well moment and he lifted his hand up so
the guy looked like he was doing ballet
and he led him he went from and they
just stepped him outside of the sitting
on his phone and I was looking at him
and I was looking at density at night
and I just I was like ro this is a year
and I go I go no fat no fat and I said
all right what do you weigh bro
and he goes paying you out of strip club
yep yeah you're not get it all yeah
anyone pick you know everywhere what are
you playing around forty [ __ ] bro Frank
Stewart is 230 dog like I wear do that
that's right guys like why do you
[ __ ] like a bird dog you thought I
got a bird yeah I know look at that ass
extreme but you're out for your male
body but if it wasn't us really haven't
got Louis NYE or Dylan I mean not me it
didn't matter and none of the girls
matter anymore I was only obsessed with
the with the giant to my right has no
fat I was just looking at hoses to work
in ass hey [ __ ] do you mind
yes I'm on my way you're breakin my life
yes and I go I didn't go to where I go
what are you waiting on me he starts
kicking me as well and then we start
doing it yeah and then I was on his lap
and I'm guessin to the world yeah Brian
dance for him yeah and I was like you
couldn't even hold me down you gonna
make me wear this wig I'm gonna freak
out and I think you like it I'd like to
have straddle one of those guys again I
bet I can't get you off at all oh my god
no no but the truth is that he [ __ ] me
and I did his law so no um so he so I
asked him I'm a freeway and he goes away
myself this morning I go or do a agus
3:47 oh and I go and this is my
impression of every Simone in the world
every custom own right after that what
do you say I'm a small guy my face yeah
my brother mom doll says you look sorry
no I I mean friends with a lot of the
Samoans when I worked for Vince McMahon
at WWF because that's like if football
don't work you can be the head butt guy
and the head butt guy all the head ball
Simoes in the history if you headbutt
them it gives them power in W if you
watch all the way back to like the wild
Samoans they get they be getting beat up
and then the white guy would make a
mistake and he would head but like Massa
and also need be like or Appa was his
name and also need be like Korra and
then you just are whipping your ass
because that's Vince's raises mentality
like I got a little easier he'll the bad
guy just the way it worked in because I
made him a lot of money in Detroit in
the AMC yeah so hey oh that's the way I
go yeah so I would meet all these guys
and they gave me this girl to work with
and they call her Tamina Samoan girl
she's a daughter of Jimmy Superfly Snuka
oh and she's talking about she's talking
another guy was super you know buff Jack
pro wrestlers and I'm walking off with
him talking them and I said man she's
she pink man she's strong and she's not
fat she's just strong thing he goes rope
she deadlifts more than 90 percent of
the roster I was like yeah they're not
that big and he goes no no no no the men
and the women why cuz I was like shut up
bro and he's like no no no dude look at
her legs watch her work out and watch
guys take plates off when they work in
it's a very kind of strong growth
friendly - yeah once a whole day thanks
to you and then they're good they drain
your time a different animal may have
seemed to linger
okay in a bar they say grab the guy by
sasso to us grab the guy by a bottom of
the steel the mandible the mandible
submission hold on the main kind of did
this motorcycle teeth off went like that
give me the bottom teeth back the curb
stomping would take - let me just tell
you already
I was in a bar and someone pulled out my
bottom teeth yes I don't know that I
would ever leave like I don't know I'd
ever leave my home what happen to you
nothing someone pulled out my [ __ ]
magic you're on a date you know Wow
yeah she's like oh my god wait game over
who first out of that teeth who that
move you like dude you know what I just
did what a moment I'll just hold up that
dude's teeth get the [ __ ] outta here
that stronger I created with the video
yeah I wonder if I just told his ears
off and then squash his head if I
squished if I squeezed it had a hard-on
it's like Brennan could do this you know
it talks about like where you could grab
the average guy and put bring them
against your chest I don't know about a
brain and reanima story about again
today where I want to talk about pulling
a man close to my tent he went trolling
him it's really weird anyway but when
you're big you can do weird jujitsu [ __ ]
on regular guys that doesn't work on
bigger and Chaplin just with mass right
I don't even have her this is your
chicken story where I was in a bar and I
knew I was about to lose a fight but I
remembered my brother telling me that
just hit hit and make sure you get a
punch in so I had to make sure he
doesn't want to fight you twice I hit
him as hard as I could and right in the
mouth and he just turned his head and
turned back to many goes son you're
gonna have to do a lot better than that
I was like oh that's Lawrence Taylor
remember like when he blew the
quarterback is on old NFL Films and Lord
seller picks up the offensive line of
the phone you have to do a better job
than that that's the worst trash talk I
thought he said as I was trying to fall
he kept picking me back up and like he
would hit me again and not let me fall
down and say something else to me hey go
I was completely out of it by that's a
song it was a [ __ ] and I said to my
friends I'm like you didn't want jump in
there like no no no that was not didn't
look like that was gone I don't know
not a real bang have you guys had any
issues well it was to you at clubs
anything of any issues with fights
lately or nothing I have more issues
than you would think
no mostly in meet and greets and it's
just guys it's insecure dudes it's
basically what it comes down really
because they basically are like like I
got a woman will take a picture with me
and a guy will be like you want to
picture man nah it's all hurt I'm like
okay you're diggin pigs later you can't
[ __ ] my wife I'm like well first of all
I probably could but that's why let's
rephrase that like I know I'm not gay I
don't really want to [ __ ] your wife like
this is not just a picture man yeah I
don't react to that stuff but then they
start to they poke at you to the point
where like you know man I'm just saying
just keep your [ __ ] like I'm not
touching your wife so I did have one guy
who so we're taking the picture and
depends if you're taller than me a
shorter than me where my hand goes if
I'm taller than you it goes around the
shoulder if I'm sure than you it has to
go under all your back the woman was
taller than me so it went under but I
didn't it's not like if my hand was
disappeared he could see it was right
here wasn't anything like that
he was like move your [ __ ] hand did I
go what he goes move your [ __ ] hand
you should have died if you should've
just wiggle and I go well I laughed and
I go okay and I just shook it like that
he was no I'm serious man don't touch my
wife and I was like we're taking a
picture dude and he was like then don't
take the [ __ ] he was he told the camera
he goes then don't take the [ __ ]
picture I'm like I'm holding the camera
[ __ ] like you don't have your all
dates at all here picture when I put ass
he came right at me and the guy he
mopped in dude it was really bizarre but
we never have issues like that that's
also cuz I'm with you too yeah now all
of you get manhandled by bigger guys
when I'm alone they kind of like bigger
guys will manhandle you they like you
and they'll take liberties with your
body there's no resolution and I'll grab
you by you but I'll get punched Rockets
yeah they hit you or like or this is not
for long you doing that in class all
right when he's around very soon the
chimpanzee politics that happened
because well I'll get I'll get kind of
jumbled around and there's a lot of work
when I'm with them when I'm with the big
dog they there's an alpha status at
house yeah all of a sudden they they're
very polite they did behave what never
is there anybody steps out a room that's
how sociology was invented like the
biggest strongest guy got the most food
he had all the women and the smaller
guys couldn't do [ __ ] because he could
just whoop him and so finally they
literally got together and said Amen one
man one woman did we gotta work things
out for like I did with it and then a
guy saying oh [ __ ] you and he goes okay
you could kill me but all of us
can kill you yeah so we're gonna
separate some of these rules and that's
how they dealt with outfits better check
this out I just read this fascinating
thing in the goat no go go
in Rwanda there's a troop of chimpanzees
about 100 of the show there's 150 to go
go did you sell out the trip ready
actually sold out in the go-go detail
and abednego girl you'll wake me up
before you go there are seven people
it's an outdoor auditorium for a flying
for two days to do the stuff like a
sunken amphitheater him yes go guys
IndieGoGo tour in the middle bring your
malaria pills Go Go it's just really
truly we will be only very hot in the
region so it's going to be jumping make
sure you don't even wait that bring your
anti-venom everyone we're good there's
no religion water you'll die crocodiles
are everywhere so in Nagoya they studies
150 chimps and it's a true band they've
been studying for 20 years and they
noticed that they control an area of
about 11 square miles
Donnie model that is right there and
intercept the male's would break off new
about 15 to 20 and they couldn't figure
out what they were doing because they
weren't hunting and they weren't walking
together they would walk in a
single-file line along their border the
key military stone yeah they were on the
border also they were gonna do some on
the deal no I'll check this out so what
they would do is they'd be walking just
along where they controlled they
actually knew their border because there
was another troop of chimpanzees over
here the control in that area and get
guess what they would do when they like
excuse me when they would say a
chimpanzee
especially a male just from the other
troupe who happened to have been waiting
around in Libin and they would come in
and [ __ ] murder that - yeah and so
they had they cake murdered about 23 24
chimps from the other tribe now here's
what's really crazy when they would
murder that she left an ace of spades
whenever they have no check this out
they're there for that as well and their
babies would move over - oh that is you
know that right so so about a
out 15 years later they increase their
territory by 23% Jesus and it was the
first case where they realize that man
primates primates are actively involved
not only in murder but in taking more
terror - they wanted to expand and there
are cuttings are a lot more like Justin
people will remain that whole alpha
status when you study chimpanzees and
stuff and you study is just sort of how
they can be they're really capable of
real kindness to each other but chimps
solve everything with you know what else
there's been a real the nature in my
front yard the last week their benefits
every morning Hawks are on my wife's car
there's a picture did I there was one on
my Instagram of just a hawk perched on
my wife's car and so he gives you a
picture of how violent nature can be
there was a bird just simply flying
across my driveway and I'm getting out
of my car and I hear and then poof and I
look up and there's just a puff of
feathers this hawk grabbed another bird
out of midair got it but here's a crazy
thing is if you're that bird you were
just like I'm gonna you're in your head
you're like what am I gonna do today
well I'm gonna fly home game over yeah
yeah and they're all destroyed to this
face oh hey chin bring up owl snatches
cat I think that says on YouTube owls
they're vicious right oh they are also
write up predators and they have been
known to kill cat did I fed one at an
animal park where they let me hold a
chick head and this giant thick glove
and the thing literally in three flaps
flew across like a probably a 20-yard
span and landed on my arm was so much
weight that I literally took steps
backwards and just one bit to chick head
swallow and I literally sitting there
looking at that like you watch Discovery
Channel as a kid in the 80s I guess what
I would do it to around the Virgin and
pray our boy yeah illness around
strangles the cat well that's an owl
killing a cat right there that's a
lovely
that's what strangles it mid-flight
that's actually dangling it on the side
of my bed that looks like an eagle that
doesn't even look like a hawk it's a ha
ha
look baby indigo who you think the wind
is [ __ ] bad who thinks when when this
yeah yeah brutal Emily called Brutus
mama has been recognized you have you
say no [ __ ] game this is sure to be
commentating fights I don't think
there's an eye you should have an option
to listen to him batteries in place for
real are you choking them out yeah it'd
be great you're that boy I didn't know
Hawks could actually do that onto a
towel is on
that cat is getting the worst oh that
cat is not birds or not I mean that's so
cruel look at that [ __ ] ah because don't
you think the bird could probably finish
it in a different fashion if he wanted
to first don't give a [ __ ] if he's gonna
exert a few calories as possible to I
mean it is will no good today I'll say
what man you don't want to go down that
rabbit hole Lucas is most vicious Hawk
and Eagle attacks on cats and kids
hey man who the [ __ ] is filming off
easily take it in yet Hawk I feel
Brenda's not a blue pill guys go ahead
would you guys break that up right there
now now it's your son is my yeah that's
a shame I don't like that if it's larger
than this that bird's ass yeah but if
it's someone else's I got a step back to
it yeah you don't [ __ ] with my dog
that's a big bird that is actually balls
are just balls deep into the shoulder oh
my garden cattle over here we didn't
mean to upset you hear that that's
nature with abetting a velocity block
Pat you know I wasn't thinking have to
watch out for birds of prey you can't
hear him coming oh my man's
ex-girlfriend was walking her little dog
on like Runyon Canyon one of those top
canyons in the evening out we all boom
took the leash right out her hand come
on
and she just sat there and he was like
dude she couldn't even cry so great
happen when you shot and then it was
just gone she couldn't even see it to
like what it was just oh the Eagle
attacks you could let go oh yeah okay I
mean I guess that might have been
territorial though he can you got three
very rare Alateen Eagle attacks Wolf's
which is down at the bottom there
how could an eagle attack a wolf I mean
I know how I could but he goes oh give a
[ __ ] there yeah God look at that [ __ ]
what is that is that a pterodactyl I
mean hey by the way it go up your right
hand up to her I have to ask you a
question then I'm sure you guys have
talked about but him is there a
similarity you would also know between
training to fight and comedy like it
seems like is there a similarity with
because with like jujitsu because you
know you're thinking moves ahead right
and it's kind of a puzzle and to me
comedy is always a puzzle when I get on
stage figuring jokes out is like a
puzzle is there any similarity that you
guys have found between the two
obviously there's immense differences
but your approach to it or anything like
that I think maybe the like the hard
work and the work after but like if I
want to get better at jujitsu I can
schedule a class with henna at 9:00 a.m.
and go get better jujitsu right with
comedy I mean you can ride but you get
to me you can't just sit down like every
more at 9:00 and sit down and write I'm
gonna come up with my material for the
next show it doesn't really work like
that yeah but to me I almost added a hit
you like it yeah well I'll get a concept
like Brian King to my show at Gotham and
you've never seen the show so he watched
and I and I said hey min let me know
what you think I should work on and he's
like oh you could fill this in here and
since that I've been obsessed with
filling that yeah when you have a topic
and yet for me like I'll set my timer my
clock for either 20 minutes or 30
minutes and it's fun because I don't do
anything but sit in the chair and I love
that because sometimes nothing happens
at 30 minutes but sometimes something
wonderful happens so you you discover
something when you sit still and you try
to just focus on a question or on a
topic of like my stand-up so so the
hardest thing for me now is it's not so
hard to make people laugh after all
right there's a bag of tricks I know how
to do that but to really combine making
people laugh and talking about what I
actually really care about what I'm
worried about where I see the world
going the things that matter that
becomes very different what do you do
John yeah everyone has their own
routines that's what I was about to say
I grew up in calmly clothes all your
father's
a picture and a autograph on some club
he helped my daughter back club he gave
their money The Improv out here on
Melrose and he's bad pictures and all
there's another one I meant Tom but I
used to go there and I had a spiral
notebook and actually showed this
notebook to Chris Titus because I used
to watch him perform there and I would
write down the comics name since I was
12 years old but would just let me go in
there he didn't care I had a lot of you
know different type father figures and
my mom just wanted me to get to know who
my dad was so I'd be in there late late
late hours listening the filthiest jokes
the filthiest comics the nicest the
cleanest male/female Elayne Boosler like
you didn't Matt everybody man I would
write down kind of what I thought they
were doing from age 12 and I think I
stopped I was like 21 22 one so I was
legally allowed a book maybe maybe one
day but uh but that's why when you ask
the question I was confused because the
two of you and I'm very familiar with
with both Brian's and Josh's work is
such a different style I would wonder if
he even approached a joke the way you do
because you really do it's like a jigsaw
puzzle and you'll see all the pieces and
you can put it together the same joke a
million different ways yes and still
make people laugh but I don't know a lot
of guys who do that well I mean that's
why I'm always curious about people's
what their processes me to some
fascinated by field so what you're what
you do Brian I couldn't do
he's like Zen like I need why go in the
garden and the jokes come to him I love
that a bird lands on your shoulder with
words the joke to you yeah no I I you
that silence I can't do I need white
noise
I need headphones I need to be in a
shower I really matter like white spot
on black spots like you guys are right
until early sometimes too though I was
hiking walking yet move in New York I
need to moving on up around the edges
when I write the best so onstage is when
I really just brief loads I I go up with
like I go I really like the story I
really like and so for me I'm all to go
out and I get onstage and that's how I
do it I'll tell the story five times
exactly how it happened because for me
the funniest stories and you're real
funny comes from the truth of the story
so what part of the story works in truth
and then I shed the part that the truth
part
doesn't work were you working that out
it because like when I was talking to
Joey Diaz I think it was on his podcast
or this one the thing is done his he's
saying
me at the Comedy Store and I can't go up
there and work it anymore he goes
because it's sold out every night yeah
there's like legend legend legend legend
if you go up and do through trying out
material people go out flat so really
here's a stylish man
right now you're you got a at the store
I think the three of us are there
tomorrow night yeah yeah yeah a p.m.
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I'd realtor there
yeah there you go guys I can't say yes
there you go yeah anyways but you were
saying like I can't go the store anymore
I stopped out because the road you're
going to follow bill burns no oh my girl
all right don't you do it on the road I
do don't you I squeeze it in the middle
so I'll do stuff that I know is working
up front and I know it works at the end
but if I need to try 20 minutes or new
stuff I'll squeeze it right there's a
mindset too though because you can get
away with your bag of tricks you can get
away with writing and really getting a
crowd going especially on the road but I
guess it goes back to sort of try to be
as original as you can trying to be
original trying to really surprise
yourself that's not but also you can the
guys who are come up with new [ __ ] you
can tell their specials aren't on
Netflix they're not doing ticket sales
well again it's very easy to tell people
who are doing the same [ __ ] or they
can't cook they can't get lost in the
shuffle because there's monsters out
every tweet and I follow a lot of
comedians when guys are touring almost
everyone has a hashtag that says all new
stuff and they have to have that out
there because with the internet now it's
crazy my old man back in the day to get
better his Road Dogg was this great
comic named Tim Thomerson Tim even did
some movies in the 80s he was uh he was
an Iron Eagle he was the dad that like
the kid has to go save he's 15 he steals
a jet and saves his dad and like Iraq
and he made a dad he was in Cherry three
thousand or ten miles asian he's a
really cool character actor but he's a
great stand-up comic and whether it was
him or Jay Leno or a few other guys that
he rolled with they would trade sets and
my dad would say hey man do my set I've
done that I want to see real would you
bring the village boy yet
okay so he's not alone in that oh I'm
waiting they used to do he has this
fridge sad sailor he'd say hey man how
does done he said do all my stuff and
Tim would go up there and and just
basically make fun of my dad and do his
whole [ __ ] set and then my dad would
go up and they'd seen each other so much
they were Road Dogg like they were like
not doing I've done that man to have ice
that makes you love or anything live
from your material did you discover
anything right that way I just fine like
I once you're my dad was young you got
to remember so he was still like
learning it he was 22 when he when he
died so this was a very you know young
science for him when you're older and
you've been doing this and you're once
you're 30 years old and you've been
doing this as long as you guys have
you're not going to learn anything that
you can't teach yourself right for the
most part in your specific trade but my
dad had only been doing it for two years
and he was 19 years old I did cry
informed on Johnny on The Tonight Show
and then three weeks later Johnny said
hey I want you to host it for me I'm
going on vacation and he's still the
youngest guy ever to host of The Tonight
Show so like that for him that was like
hey let me see what you got and then he
would if Tim did something better he
would take it him put it back I don't
never do stand-up rented you I don't
want to I don't want to stand on the
same floor blurred floorboards of my
five yeah yeah if I learn new stuff but
I definitely get reminded of things that
I should be you know there's so many
there's so many ways to do comedy and
there's so many you know tricks and
there's so many ways to get to a
punchline and so I've been really
focused on stories I've been telling our
stories I have a story I tell my act at
32 minutes long right but I love it I
love taking people on a journey but then
because of it I started forgetting other
skills that I used to have that I needed
to re-implement I learn actually I
remembered it from watching daliyah
special you know Kalia does really want
a man on fire one yeah you know he does
really well he he does not he mines that
joke for every punchline you're gonna
find he finds every angle he just keeps
tag tag tag tag tag tag tag and uh
whether you think he's funny or not that
that is what is subjective he's colluded
but that I think he's lawyers but that
style that aligning of continuing
to mine never giving up on a joke or
never saying the joke is finished
because I had gotten into so Eddie
Izzard does that right yeah Eddie Izzard
are you caught you keep searching with
so it's never done never done so
important to keep honing and to keep
like looking at that story because you
can find so much in it and that's what I
do I always go back to my chair and I
add things so I think about helping me
out the most efficient me I've been
doing coming for two minutes just
sold-out theater it's so lifted I'm
stressed and this is why I have you guys
here because I need to come up with an
act like I got that six minute really
here I texted a he goes through Michigan
he goes what the [ __ ] he goes like this
he goes what the [ __ ] is happening I get
this text and he goes like this Holy
Mother of God
no he goes uh um sold out to theater
shows in England and my two shows in
Dublin in under two minutes
what the [ __ ] is happening I go Holy
Mother of God I have a hit podcast a TV
show and I've been doing the road for
fifteen years and I still can't tell
clubs mm a factor goes Brendan Schaub
fans oh they're me and I go and I go bye
bye Bubba bond and he goes he goes that
don't piss me off for all sloppy I go
congrats for y'all this is exciting
honestly I'm not surprised I told you
you were going to be a star he goes well
I'm not a star let's take it easy and
everything else then I go through this
other thing I go you got a lot of stuff
going for you and you all you need now
is time on stage and he goes well this
big dick doesn't hurt though - ah - oh
no - then I got another text Anita and a
big dick
nothing then I get say it bro nothing
else I get no say it about that and I go
come on bro don't get greedy so welcome
to like Van Damme and blood work with
you I came all the cotton and he's like
yo Steven
what I was going to say is like I've
been at the comic store so much it's
literally my favorite place on earth
it's also the the hardest place on
anything yeah for especially for a guy
like me because it's not fine kids and
snot blend shop pains it's like you know
there's your thunder yeah so for me that
that's like the mech if I I know if
something works there then on the road
and when it's my fan base is gonna go
really Jamie used to work for my dad but
dude he's described what I was saying is
what when I'm there like you know Aussie
Brian you have seen me do a million
shows but you know bro going to be the
D'Elia be the Bert Kreischer should be
the Tom Segar and all and go man I love
this your thing about Vimy so much yeah
but matter how about if I sure will kill
before I did my this is not happening
and he was like oh I love this I would
focus more than this yeah and it's just
because you know Bert Kreischer he's a
monster and he's a storyteller so in I'm
a storyteller so when I get a note from
him
it's [ __ ] gold no I'm not saying this
for your benefit I'm saying it for your
listeners when you have people who you
respect and legends giving you advice
without you even asking it's because
they like you it's because they respect
you and they want you to refine your
skill as quickly as possible
don't be the knowingness dog on the
block accept that inform how your guess
I will take your you will comedy for
everyone
just like I always thought Chelsea was
good for comedy and Dane was good for
comedy because you're bringing eyeballs
the comedy that wouldn't normally have
come to comedy and for me I know some
people like it's like when Dane will use
him as example people like bogan and his
fans I'm like his fans had never known
comedy before yeah no I buy you're
hungry no diggity eyeballs to comedy and
that's for the same with you like you're
bringing eyeballs the comedy that
weren't there yeah I think that so it's
good the successes yeah is it now I
couldn't sell out a [ __ ] coffee shop
in London I mean not good so I count if
you and I went to London over this and
we we co-headlined a theatre yeah how
many seats think we I don't know
so what prints five gas container so I
mean sweet but it's amazing dude but but
that's important to be a sponge and to
watch I think as much comment as you can
I still I don't know about you do you
watch other not a lot i watch old
special I do I love watching burn stuff
and I love watching guys that I respect
and being ok I would have never thought
of that
why would I have never thought of his
Schwartz are they connected and I try to
assume about like God like it's amazing
you know you look at different paths
people take on their choices for comedy
and I'm like man how did they go down
that path Kitson so that is why I watch
because I'm like I need to let my brain
open up in different directions the
difference is always get one thing like
yeah yeah we can't go my god sometimes
yeah I had to do a set before homeboy
who do I love did the three Mike's
Neil Brandon red I do rap before him and
I was a comma I love Neil I know he's
also dealing like I'm gonna watch meal
and he did it I was like man does anyone
have a razor blade for I Drive home yeah
yeah you can't well that was a lot
John's like oh my god he's brilliant you
got a hangout there's bird brain no I
got thank you thank you like a Sigma
hello in this seven-minute okay you got
to give yourself a little more latitude
my life really I was never think like
she does you no good unless that
limitless still comes any day now it'll
never have because if I didn't I ain't
sharing that with Noah but why the comic
is important to expand your horizons and
to read and yes thank into and to
formulate opinions and even outrage at
the world and in a sense of injustice or
say yo what you just said is one of the
most important things stand-up comedians
have ever done they will discuss
something that normal people will never
talk about because it's [ __ ] horrible
because it sucks because it was the
Holocaust and nobody wants to talk about
six million Jews died nor 20 million
Russians dying or the half a million
American and the happen nobody wants to
talk about that but when a comic looks
at it and they bring history and real
[ __ ] in their set and all of a sudden
make it funny
I'm not joking it inspires those
conversation
later on it inspires people to learn
more about the Lateran of free speech
without that we don't live in a kind of
country that respects the First
Amendment anymore you can say the wrong
thing and you will be censored you will
lose your job comics comics we are the
last Griffon even yeah even Judaism well
I don't agree if we rule was alive you'd
be kicking people in their nuts right
now
yeah we did that roast of David Ortiz's
Big Papi involved right I saw some that
okay so it was a new Adam Ray who added
with me burr Anthony Mackie the kid guy
from The Avengers Rob Gronkowski Dustin
Pedroia
I saw Rob's Sarah Tiana Adam ray you
know Lenny Clarke yeah I [ __ ] love
imagine my magic I saw I don't Leilani I
only really close you know Lenny's jack
now we're doing it judge already a huge
man no no no 260 man lost his weight Wow
he's about your size in Jack look I
didn't say my smaller another figure why
he's a big boy
not anymore no Lenny has always been big
frame and then he's got a six-pack what
Jesus hey but I'm certainly sure it got
you only going to be a 65 but Rob got a
job on that is that what you did amazing
thing right so we did that I did this
wrote it for him but and we look not a
County Central Roast it was for charity
so we told everybody when they bought
the tickets it's going to be rough and
when they got there the first guy who
warmed the crowd said hey it's gonna be
rough there's a road and we had nothing
coachman from ESPN right he was like hey
guys this is gonna be rough don't get
Ilocos remember them so we all I mean
there were some horrible joke Sarah
Tiana did a joke about Jose Fernandez
the pitcher who died he's holding that
road accident I mean she has went there
she kept a rolling stone he's got a
little bit about a lot of roads so yeah
they're old man I forget it might have
been something about the you know that
boat that Ortiz came over on she was
like even Jose Fernandez when they got
on that boat we were all like that's
good yeah
very hot another fall suppose way
killing and throwing out some [ __ ]
rough jokes
Gronk gets up there now this goes to
your point that comics can say [ __ ] but
other people can Gronk opened and I have
nails whole set I had made fun of him I
had said something what did I say about
him it's kind of was funnier at the
roast but I said something to the extent
of you know Rob's great football player
and he scored a lot of touchdowns he
also looks like he's got a touch of the
down right people he did not like old
brothers Unni otherwise to the damn yeah
he older had just a touch it right it's
just like God when you know wealthiest
animals don't that is a pitch of the
strings up with a key goes to me goes
hey man I saw Josh wolf wife backstage
and he goes Josh you know what a
Cleveland steamer is I go yeah he goes
let me tell you I go no I know what it
is man and he goes no let me tell you I
go okay he goes you know it is here's
when you [ __ ] I do yeah
and he goes that's what I did to your
wife I'm like just say no that's not a
roast joke that's like that's like a
call to action
hey crow why don't you off the script
into the script I [ __ ] on your wife yeah
let's Remy wrote you jokes
stick to those yeah no hot reads in calm
again let's sing a couple of the jokes
that he got in trouble for he [ __ ] up
he told a joke about why don't do he
goes to me why don't you play football
I'm like why he goes because I can't get
the quarterback I'm like you messed up
you messed up that joke it's the other
way around but that's why we play
football to get the quarterback wait so
he's [ __ ] you got a professional be
anybody's beside anything like way too
stupid he told a buddy on our Vivaro
probably wasn't very funny but he also
said although some great jokes yeah he
really did he and he's a professional
football player
and he did it for charity out of the
goodness of his heart we raised hundreds
of thousands of dollars for sick kids he
did come out and he slayed with some
jokes and he [ __ ] took more abuse on
that stage than anybody else because he
doesn't get the past
he totally you know he doesn't get the
pass and he took a ton of [ __ ] and he
that was the probably outside of Lenny
the second Camus guy the people only guy
who got in trouble because the people
want to poke at you he's not a comic
nothing that we said even made the
papers yeah grrraah rocket into gorillas
on that range but there's hate for Gronk
he gets to do whatever he wants whenever
he wants he's rich he's good-looking
with a pinch um I said gets to do you
know he's a champion he gets to do he
dogs happily yes so if you get a chance
to go in have him as well Avel Adams
pill you suck at football
no actually wanted uh we're broke nah
man I was like a hundred milligrams but
here's uh will you suck I've shot you
ball ring demon playing the game by the
way that was mentioned a couple times
the Rose but they had they had like wow
that one was red but did you see Drake
hosting the NBA Awards and his stand-up
bad no brilliant you did you like a show
that I didn't love the show though I
didn't love I didn't like the overall
shot thought it awkward with I don't
know if they're going to do they know
gagging I thought great I'll see people
writing I get that but he's knows
execute these days highly received the
one but Rose on Kenny cos Kenny so what
they would do is Drake was the host and
it's when they give out like the MVP and
coach of the year and all they did it
all at once this time all at once - I
think he liked it so maybe I don't you
know like Kenny and and Charles Barkley
yeah and those guys that et ICTs they
had like a balcony yeah so they would go
like the muppet the old guys in hog
arrest which is a little weird it was
but if they still do their say so the
other thing so then Kenny in there's
always kind of this kind of cloud over
Drake died he doesn't write his own
music Kenny goes man did Drake write his
own jokes up there and then it goes
commercial nobody goes back Drake has
the mic and you can you just use like oh
like that I heard what you said Kenny
when I was backstage because that's
funny coming from the guy who the most
acuity but he roasted them like pretty
really really pretty bad you know that's
funny coming from the one guy something
that is the most replaceable up there
which is true man there's a lot of
sensitive rappers into this alright man
sensitive I thought I was laughing at
Drake's jokes I was doing but you you
but we criticized these guys so much
what happened to Gronk is exactly why
celebs and athletes don't go out and do
fun [ __ ] no way I would never do that
let your guard down for a second but
here's the deal let's take for an
example on the same team Russell Wilson
and Richard Sherman well Russell Wilson
gets [ __ ] for not taking a stance he's
too vanilla
he's like Jordan he doesn't stand up but
Richard Sherman get [ __ ] for talking too
much he's so weak more famous though but
but we [ __ ] we they're [ __ ] if they do
and they [ __ ] if they don't right but
that's our coulter right like like
everyone you can say if you go online
right now and you n go is more famous
Richard Sherman or Richard Sherman
probably there's also Russell Russell
women have a CRI we're back in UCR so
that's a different story
anyways but if you go online right now
and you went to forms about Kanye West
you would think the entire world [ __ ]
in hate the guy yeah because how does he
know how I'm Alex but are you kidding me
or got somebody like Kim Kardashian like
oh my god how does she not commit
suicide and then Kanye West released a
shoe and a lace out in seconds oh yeah
Kim Kardashian her makeup she sold more
makeup in two hours in the history of
the world was he telling the life lotto
dream and I say all people are so
committed you don't want to say like the
are mind if you so much hate yeah that's
what people are gay a good sign in some
way said that's what I think that about
you that's what the big baller various
women banking on yeah yeah turn a few
night of anybody as well in like with
with the khaki movie they just have tax
and be with the Kathy Griffin thing is
like I was supposed to be like any
publicity is good publicity especially
as a comic yeah it's what she has an
athlete ooh I drunk some people are
gonna go especially his bro fanbase I'm
like that's [ __ ] the lair all the
Bros Brandon it was five or six articles
that hammered him TMZ SR headline was so
ridiculous Gronk goes in on blacks Jews
and fat ass Big Papi come on it was such
a [ __ ] word that's what I mean though
it's like that's what you still have and
a lot of people in the press I feel like
have an agenda
sure and then watch all clicks like
evangelist rah
killed it doing stand-up for the first
time people and if they say Josh wolf
makes fun of blacks a be like whoo yeah
yeah they did no quick right there they
want to advance their careers and that's
a part of the game and that sucks but
that's the way it goes man like it's
there shouldn't no one should be allowed
to video someone when they get off an
airplane and they're walking to a car
because that's not a media event and
very definition in Webster's [ __ ]
Dictionary of the news is a media event
that will be covered and someone walking
from A to B is not that but it happens I
get I gotta make a living so that's what
they do and you either talk to him or
you don't I saw one of the very most
Boston things ever in Boston it mostly
just because either guys that I just
remember we're outside of Fenway and
this dude was clearly shit-faced clearly
shouldn't write and he's ordering a
hotdog and he takes a bite of the hotdog
immediately projectile ha ha
then eat the rest my photographer what
and I was like what just happened right
there first bite look at [ __ ] baby
Shannon you can tell he was like no he
was trying to fill up his stomach about
your alleged shooting a little bit but
many were Simpson yeah yes like this
point does mouthing he was like and I
was like god this dude is like yeah yeah
this is okay yeah dude you can't do that
JIT did you see uh and I don't know
Devan I doubt it chin on I'm balls deep
on Howard Stern I love Howard Stern but
he had ed Sheeran on an edge in just
straight-up quit social media he did
there was quite a move he quit because
in office he's killing me 33 million
last year and I don't know if social
media for him it might be different but
he was saying it's so negative and yes I
don't look like Justin Bieber I don't
look like Justin Timberlake so I'm out
tickets and people make fun of the way
I'm going here yeah sure you know just
talking about everything about Albert
you change into that Alaska we can we
can still make fun yeah and everyone was
injured you can [ __ ] you can shove
him into literal you know yeah you know
what else you can do still for whatever
you know you can't make fun you know
what racist thing you can still do on TV
is an Asian accent for whatever reason
you can still do an Asian accent and
people are like okay that's funny
Reenactment is still oh you're here
David tells joke is all joke about I'm a
racist but I mean you need graces I
don't like Eskimos I hold rallies and
we're like down with none ooh this is my
favorite to tell joke ever dude favorite
tell Jo gave her funniest mother and I
don't know why it struck me so funny is
he was like hey if you ever see a grown
man naked running down the street turn
and run with him because something
really Bad's behind him yeah that's a
sixth no dudes running sprint and naked
down Billy
those are one of those random jokes that
really good comics throw in between yeah
money jokes yes rest in peace I've
talked to him before who do I love so
much Richard Jeni Richard Jeni and he
would tell these stories Oaks right he
would go on these like seven to eight
minute jokes and he would stop one the
crowd claps he takes a drink and he
starts another and in between one of
them it just it's quiet he's just very
calm on the mic he goes hey here's
something you don't hear very much in
Texas yeah that was one hell of a Bar
Mitzvah now and he just jumped you today
Joe and I remember I was like 14 wafers
I was like what the [ __ ] the hell would
I end up here Vani Oh today did that
Devon just like he's just killing a
Romany so he he go hysterical Jews are
clogging up the internet but all I got
on oh hey I got the feelin I would get
raided this at The Comedy Store it feels
going to introduce me and he enters bit
like this
he said he's sitting it and he's gone
and he goes this is even part of the bay
because this is a true story my friend
got bit by a game in West Hollywood so
we'll see what happened that's my bad
nose no seriously my finger he goes on
fire gay guys and we're truce what's
gonna happen he's just dead sis I was
like it was so random it was so random
he just was like so I'll keep you guys
play my son he's on our podcast and he
started talking I he made money we made
money for a while we were handing
we were renting like small furry animals
like guinea pigs and things after after
raves and we were like come again
yeah maybe gonna side your hands want to
feel something warm and furry
here he goes he's not don't get crazy
cuz we take the teeth out this is not
going to bite you much what the [ __ ] is
even going to look at ripping the teeth
as a I mean it's not he killed feel he
feels so funny he'll come offstage and
be like I don't think I'd give I was
like feel you they were you were opening
sides people were yanking their [ __ ] lot
of legal paid though income he is like
and I don't know it's kinda I have no
doubt it's kind of it happened for him
because I watch him I'm like this dude
is bordering on next level sonic pop
yeah yeah right he's top 5 yeah he's
gonna pop his stories do that nobody is
telling a story like him and he makes up
words on stage that's my favorite part
like he's got a separate bill Daniel
Arielle and I had a judgment on him cuz
he was on road rules and he was younger
and I just MTV I got into him I didn't
know anything about him I was wrong and
I saw him one day and I went and I could
went up to me so yeah it's a kid it's
how a rigid gendered to me that still
follows him like offs bring up the old
Vaughn people yeah we are from MTV where
yeah NASA like 15 years ago I said would
you like a video joke here no he was
like ah no he's on real real world and
what I don't laughing comics together
and we level Thomas Tanner yeah we both
got voted off but then this was the
first year they had done most most comic
demos downloadable I'm about to tell you
guys something that's terrible but I'm
gonna tell you anyways because I think
that it's the it I can't get in trouble
for it now I don't think it's been many
years but I had a friend of mine who was
like he called me like hey here you're
on Last Comic downloadable and I go yeah
and he goes I can set up a program to
just give you like a vote every 10
seconds I'm like really did like the gel
being all your voting he goes yeah I'm
in the office right now and I go what
and he goes yeah it's just guy just have
to press a button right now I just set
it up exactly 10 minutes probably do I
go yeah you press the [ __ ] motor you
cheating your way all right when I come
I would go sir I go don't press a button
if you do I'm going to be
Thank You Taksim did you do my leave
then you're fat now I am way smarter I'm
winking cuz I have something in my eye
right now but you have a doorknob you
brother by the way I've wanted to say
that out loud for seven good the statute
of limitations I figure seven years is
about that
well when tomatoes go steal be me bro
you had a double programmer apparently
he had a better house I'm gonna push a
button that's all I'm gonna do this a
minute button
yeah and I why haven't you already done
it I said why are you following me
yeah you should have Justin and you
should have just made me feel good about
your don't I'll tell you a real friend
just do it and tell me I'm blowing I
would live to live like a scumbag
depressive brother but I've never been
tempted to do something really bad
because it was so easy like if you ever
like seen something that you could take
yeah yeah you guys kids besides sex
right yeah yeah yeah I found I saw him
college i that there were friends but
they were ordering Stila steroids opera
a site and they're shown that means how
easy it was and the first time like it's
that easy and I was like oh but I'm up
to the drug test and I could that just
happens as long as you pass it in the
first time and then I was like God in
for it I can't play it for a second and
I'm like good my ovens if I can't take
out youth and if I can't take it and
then they're like I've kids sucks and
the guys can't be worth it I'm like what
if I got caught my dad like you're the
worst yeah
you were the bed that's all I could
think my dad's not like you're a
complete loser man well I paid so dearly
NFL it's other sports they call you on
it but in the NFL a lot of fans like
they do what you gotta - they don't be
that dumb or yeah at the bottom like
just superstar you've got steroids
supporters people like that's bullsh
we lost God yeah when I was 26 years old
I remember they were these guys that
were dead drug dealers they were they
were and they were talking about how
much money they were making a week and
it was crazy I can't member was gonna
spy like 25 grand
not that life one guy for you one guy
said he made forty five grand a week in
a month and I was like I was like
thinking about the summer time and I was
thinking about
girls and what I could do and I remember
I said what would you have to do and he
goes you just drive the package
literally you just drive it from you
know Connecticut to from Fairfield to
[ __ ] you know this place in the city
that's it and that you just pop your
trunk they pull it out and you just
drive
I remember just gone that seemed so do
bad yeah so I did why isn't everybody
doing minute right now
thought about I was like forty five
grand of course that's not true and of
course that wouldn't happen but I
remember to say to myself I would die
just apologize about it I know another
guy who's kind of famous who told me the
story about um this is crazy he goes he
went to take a piss he's famous and he
might take a piss and he didn't it
wasn't before he's famous wasn't making
any money
he's peeing my guy came in and goes hey
and he knew the guy hit the guide then
the dis party and so he kind of knew him
a little bit and he was older and the
guy looks at me goes I'll give you
$1,000 if you let me suck your dick a my
friends very straight my friend was
United and stopped anyway I need that
thousand dollar not like use I thought
about he really did back in a grandiy
thing I can't use I can't do it he goes
I just he could because I couldn't get
it up but he's like that guy was a
little pretty yeah needed the money he
thought about he's like oh that's a lot
of money yes possibly yeah he had to
pause I had a friend of mine who was
like and what I did that topic came up
and he said I think I got a [ __ ] from
a dude once and I go what what is that
how can you not know you think that's
like I said I go well if that's even a
song about hair dude well here goes dude
he is big big forest it was a hooker
yeah and and he was like the hooker was
pretty but I had a girl her I got a
comes out on the Adam's apple I had a
friend and he was like I you think I
never thought about doubts if there's an
Adam's apple it's telling you I'm a man
he was like man the knuckles were a
little Manny and he was like but I
didn't see a bulge and she was really
cute and it
blow job and he was like I just decided
not to find out we had a French
prostitute coffee a Frenchie Godwin
youth the bad pages for like Craigslist
or the phone God and he's like do just
stay just stay in the room with me till
she gets there just confirm like what do
you want me to do he's like I still
wanna get robbed I kinda know this guy
worthless a little bit yeah so I'll
chill out man but he make me some coffee
I'd like this good confident so I'm
chilling there and she's like or he or
she's an hour late King King comes door
I'm like Scott looked like a DN from the
[ __ ] Chicago Bears come on I knew
right away something was up his feet she
had these eggs on that could only be
made for Tom Brady Haran side support
team I'm like oh my god and I just look
like a tall I'm tall like like where I
level these odds were like to death and
you answered ago I answered the door
how much silence exist before one of
these but she was hot right like kind of
like yeah like the face was cute the
week and then had like this blob ass if
you're Ricky Williams and then she comes
in and I just look your Lego have fun
man because I did amen things went loved
yeah yes yes man I go what I guess I
don't know you know this is gonna sound
weird and don't say we don't be weird
about it right don't be weird
like there's a chance that the chick
that blew me was a dude hahaha Brandon's
life in decide 21 Oh giveaway or those
[ __ ] fingers that could wraps all the
way around your neck - I swear to God
don't go to Palm a basketball wiki with
all those Julius Peppers if they were
like this they look like ski boots on
like we'll bet they don't make ads for
woman's in those I'm I told you the one
in our show today the story on this
podcast of the one and only time I
ordered a hooker in Vegas all the time
I've ever ordered a hooker because I've
never not a hooker guy was not
interested me but my brother was like he
was poking me all night
you never had a hooker you've know how
to put I'm like why are you making me
sound like that and that makes me the
weird one
like but he's like you got to go in
tonight and when I ordered and I'll make
give you the truncated version the story
but when I call on phone we get back you
know the people who give you oh god you
did with Lee right so I picked it one of
the and I ordered it and what is this
looks the same behind us does if you
walk you don't invade about there's the
usually they're Mexican men in the gap
just handing out like Myers and like the
Hollister we've ever seen a thong so it
was hyper hook call 1999 I call and
sorry the girls is always to do it was a
her mother it was it was I call it's
late at night that she was like listen
we did most of the girls are out this is
what we got left and we had it narrowed
it down to this is what we've got left
we had it they're not click ready as I
was already we had it down to it Puerto
Rican and an Asian and she said we got
less she go I go well okay she goes it's
an easy choice for you because they're
completely different
I can either send over a petite asian or
a giant Puerto Rican and I was my
brother was in the room and I go I go
which one he goes don't say giant using
the word giant she said giant do a woman
is not sure petite asian well no I my
brother goes my brother goes my brother
go sir well have you ever have you ever
had sex with a teenage and I go yeah and
he goes have you ever even seen a giant
portobello no and I go send over the
Puerto Rican get over right now oh so
water up that chart and we're laying
he's in his bed and I'm in my bed and
and and it turns out hookers are kind of
like you know when you're when you order
a quesadilla like 2:00 in the morning
and you're fall asleep before it gets
there yeah that's what happened with the
hooker right so we we're both asleep and
there was like a little tap on the door
and I was like now little she's a giant
well the next tap was not so little whoo
and so she must have people probably
fall asleep before so I'm like I want to
see what this giant Porto Rican looks
like to have I open the door so I kind
of sneak over this was my favorite part
and I look out the spot at the little
window and she's got her thumb over the
window time moved Porto Rican I go the
massive five just covered a whole thing
you know the first thing I thought was
obviously this is somebody who's been
rejected through a people before
so she's not giving you do to me she's
not giving you a barrel her way and it
may mark yeah you know in that door
she's blowing you and your brother
oh I opened the door yeah she was six
four in heels six five that's a big girl
let me tell you something when she took
off her bra I'm not going to get to the
hole you actually went through with it
I couldn't [ __ ] her because when she
took off her bra she had one faked it
and one real one and I'm looking at her
what I look at her and I go what is that
and she was like couldn't afford to get
them both done at the same time no way
can't use a Groupon for your titties
like this is not a oh my god she already
likes it I go I'm not I don't pay [ __ ]
I got away no we told you this one we
have love my brother said to me and my
brother was fake asleep rather said to
me he goes her left titty look like
Stallone's lip like like her left titty
had bill calls it was just hanging des
with it but it was a female oh yes but I
couldn't try hate her and told her leave
I go I can't this is not happening
I was literally the gender you Darren
city state officer she pushed me this is
why this is the this char the brush me
this is the straw that broke the camel's
back you know you can kick some of that
when your two hands shove them to the
chest and they fall over you feel about
and that's what she did to me and I was
like oh this power she has sorry about
it yeah yeah yeah Thank You Natalie
incline bed yeah in some Colonel van get
it back hard before we do so you see a
little bit of this
let's go piss hard what together man
security ahh let's do it do some Corinne
of them I see that yeah sham Freddy is
that the headline say Orthodox Jewish
MMA fighter gunned down in Florida it
does that's the first guy news of the
day so he's from a PT I don't know if
you guys know this guy at all eight of
them who is that they sorted it out
clear to you Aaron Raja
no I don't know who he is God so he
there was a home invasion and there was
a fight that broke out obviously he's
defending his family and his family
himself and then they shot him and he
died 25 years old so they break into
this house he defenses to fight yep if I
broke out and this is in Florida
boqueria Tom that's not Billy Corbett
because
here yeah I know Nigeria Boko respond
and apparently like a really well liked
- knocks man ATT that's a bomb what's a
teach a lot of looks over here a lot of
guns and bullets so that's such a bummer
man
eyes my momma what a bummer
and then another bad news cop in New
York that sada all right this morning
yeah it was a female cop and she was
just ambushed and shot and killed and
then her partner ran after the guy
finally got him and killed him as
welcome he wanted to shoot him back and
it was a female
hold on chin but so the cop who chase
the guy who shot the cop that cop killed
the shooter yes yeah he killed him
because he wasn't going to go down
without a fight so he pulled out a gun
on the cop and then he shot him and if
you heard the cops call it was terrible
cuz he saw as dull it's like no no I'm
not gonna lie it was no but who brought
the bad news can ya marry a good
question know what happen at Disneyland
I know can I ask you a question and this
is interesting
now you said if you hear the cop callin
say calls like that or if you say like
Carrie Fisher's autopsy or Tiger Woods
being arrested during that DUI walk how
do you feel about all of that [ __ ] being
public knowledge like did we didn't
world we live about like that but we
didn't need to see Tiger Woods embarrass
himself just tell me he got a DUI we had
to show him you may label that's the
level of the bar so it raised I looked
up Carrie Fisher died let her die we
know everybody who knows your drugs know
I look like I got God we need but we
need to have access to this night this
call guys when you're allowed to
dehumanize a specific group of people to
the point where you can legally stalk
them as wild game is stalked then it's
nothing to find out what was in Carrie
Fisher system it's nothing to watch
Tiger Woods his marriage fall apart in
front of your eyes because he's not a
human being to you he's not he's a piece
of entertainment who you command to
entertain you all the time even when
you're dying they're dying
yeah they don't yes because it's not a
cure it's the winners bro it's nothing
to change it'll get worse the only way
to change was just oh it changes the way
Korea's get it the only way it changes
is that if people say this isn't decent
this is an amazement problem area in
Korea in Korea South Korea a classic
example
a guy got picks as an ex-boyfriend of a
girl got pictures of a pop stars and she
was naked and he went to try to sell
that a certain tabloids and one tabloid
decided to run those pictures and no one
in South Korea no one bought anything
from that tabloid again they basically
were like really blackballed you're
going to do that we're not buying your
product and that's the population I hate
sad but I but I have no she she was they
were like that Saturday so what happens
to the guy that took the picture and
what happens to the company so the guy
the guy chilling pictures got he got act
in fact there's a recording of him
trying to sell it to one dude who was
the editor of one of these tabloids and
the editor you can hear him in Korean
not only saying basically go on go [ __ ]
yourself you scumbag you're going to
sell a picture of a woman Koreans don't
play that game and and and you can hear
him and then one guy took it and that
cut the guy I guess the guy who sold the
pictures he's got nothing but death
threats
you should be another guy nobody got 150
grand here yeah morning so good was a
fascination what why the further
humiliation carrie fisher's already did
why the further humiliation for Tiger
Woods is probably is abuse struggling
people love to see those that were on
top fall yeah it is okay it will never
live it right ever this never changed
until our sort of mild tabloids suddenly
got new editors and they were straight
from England and it was that type of
media and press on the royal family and
if that mentality that they brought here
only our president was boring his kids
weren't getting in crazy trouble it
wasn't exciting so they had to create a
new royal family and it started with
Brad and Angelina and they were the king
and queen and they literally used the
same tactics that they used on the royal
family in Hollywood and it just exploded
this was in the like late 90s early
2000s
just exploded and became basically the
same type of rags that were you know
we're over there where girls are
sleeping with guys and measuring how big
their dick is and the inseam of these
like tabloid magazines and don't think
that that won't happen here one day
because it will did you see what
happened to Ricky Hatton epic no Oh Mike
but that's not happened to them all the
time when they get exposed ricky hatton
are you saying how you know he's clean
you know he's retired now but he's
saying how they screened and do drugs
anymore and then he's uh you know he
went out that night and had a party not
a friend a female friend and he did some
coke and she's while he's doing coke and
you know his fat Rolex sitting there and
he's doing mines coke she took a picture
so he's with this wife the next morning
at a fancy hotel it opens up the front
page of the newspaper
boom it's his face brother line I'll
give I'll give ten to one odds of that
newspaper paid her to do that yeah and
that is a common practice out there it
is caught they litter and there and they
know it like it's not a secret yeah they
don't remember the name they use for him
but these girls are literally paid to go
and seduce celebrities their giant angry
give that and that is that information
to said man I write how crazy I think
another common thing about waking up
being like how was last night it was
good the only experience I had with this
I what I did start actress with Kirstie
Alley and she was very heavy at the time
and and she was tabloid fodder and I
spent I don't know three months what
they're doing that read about that
that's news her weight oh do they say is
they were young children health
conscious is it now legally presided
over lettuce her I remember that you
would see pictures of you like they
would show her bending over in her
garden and you just see her ass and one
of the things I thought was amazing is
that we'd be shooting somewhere we'd be
walking and she could spot these
[ __ ] from everywhere she go
guys in the tree I see you [ __ ] and
the guy be in a tree another guy do you
see a card she'd be like that's come
back taking pictures but I was like how
do you know just because the windows are
dark and I promise you I'm coming
already uncertain wife my love unite you
Roger Thursday not anymore so much not
like it's like we live on a street that
has us and a few other people
have been in movies and music so the
only times we had followed now is
they're on vacation right so I guess
they're gone and then no one else knows
listen just put the icon in your address
and I got room you guys ready are they
allowed to take pictures in your house
the windows in your house they're not
supposed to don'twe my blue Jade scene
guys call crawl over Gwyneth Paltrow's
fins with a camera man's neck like legit
seen that and I'm called cops right away
nothing happens next day they're still
Parker's like what you know there's that
culture too you've got mean that there's
no laws so they can do it all the way
view what do you think is a sensible off
of that to respect personal you can't
come on a [ __ ] properties it to me I
was there not a picture if an yell but
Brian you can be I know they're my lorry
like that's how it should you've got
quarter-mile and unreasonable honest
lives
if you're not on their property if you
are somewhere else we allow it you can
take a picture into their property
that's terrible because you take
pictures of the people who are on their
property what did you see actually
helped ibly see Bieber's like vacation
Bahamas something yeah and he was used
with some timepiece he's butt-naked but
I just got done him fun and he's
stretching on the balcony butt-naked you
think you a huge superstar Hong yeah
yeah crossing the other balcony to
picture in this post of it by the way
you don't walk out get any choice that's
not an accident dude that's not an
accident when you get a dick like that
and you know you're Bieber you're like
why don't we just let everybody know who
the truth is maybe there are people not
all of what their photo take and they're
people who do that who set up like fake
secret photos when and paper there are
but I don't know I'll search the hotels
they go oh yeah just ready drop it and
then the TMZ fly and get rooms next
hoping to you what about what did happen
what's your name who died of it the
singer Amy anybody what do you think
should there be a punishment for because
in the last couple years I've seen more
pictures of sleeping celebrities with
girls who have just had sex with them
taking a picture of course you were
doing it like that was Adelman she's all
Luke who I just [ __ ] click that's so
thinking of her dad like what in though
where did I fail you where did I bill
where you out with that
look if if you don't have consent you
shouldn't be allowed to broadcast period
agreed it's a simple rule
if I say you can't you can't like that's
it your life introduce ya man but that's
never going to fly with anyone I accept
that I'm not asking boxing or preaching
I'm just telling you what the reasonable
law should be but see I think you can
get a few I think that's I think that
national attitudes can change
they tend they can but it will be
another button I don't know yeah there
are much money money but did I I like
that stop being I wish I can be positive
like up and there's money associated and
people are making their living based off
those photos yeah you're batshit crazy
yeah honey second generation that's a
generational evolution yeah my
great-great-great-great they will they
won't have to deal with that but they're
my great-great-great-great but they give
you example if so he goes started
posting all those pictures of those
women where was he did this guy over
they had played video games you guys so
what about an Xbox so now is a thing
yeah I mean I mean at the Gracie Academy
on fire I played video games in like
cosplay that's my life videos of him
with his cosplay mask on that skin he
sent me like going to him with this
master won't even get dogs you like that
cellebrite mad no you dude I love when
he sends it to me I'm like dude it takes
him out yeah but you usually like you
just smoked a big Jay I'm usually high
nobody's going to be music in the
beginning like a creepy mask is like
know what the [ __ ] I did I was Ryan's
referring to is there's this guy who on
the dark web leaked all those pictures
all those celebrities packed in the
phones emails and got all those pictures
like hey you know there's like a bunch
of happening or whatever if someone
hacked my phone that would be the
funniest [ __ ] in the world they I'd be
pissed with photos of my kids but if you
not joking if you saw how many photos
are of me with different superhero
[ __ ] masks on like that would be the
whole hack maybe I look at this dark
everything just check my Nova textures
on that she had sent to her boyfriend Oh
Dave have you to make and I hope so well
we have her apps or which by the way her
LC has some issues her [ __ ] I mean I
personally would have liked I wanted I
wouldn't have minded seeing Jennifer
Hudson but I personally I went Shabbat
I'm not going to look at this [ __ ] no
what's your name what's an effort
never lawrence joey is Jeff Watson's the
track that's a lot different know her
husband myself I go I just don't [ __ ]
I go I'm not going to do that because
I'm lending myself to the [ __ ] I'm
done I can't criticize it if I'm
actually going to get an Xbox one I'm
playing injustice to me two for Euro
Fighter game like Street Fighter 2 and
instead of seeing that [ __ ] to wake up
and save the universe rendered sleep a
multi rate before I forget I want to do
that pictures were strong unfortunate as
a day you do no work in the world why
are you taking a close-up of your eyes
oh my god those by acts I prepare my way
let's keep it sexy would mean I have to
look back to be like know which ones the
[ __ ] that's when you know you're
austere in a tough thank you strong
that's why she has trouble in
relationship yeah we're I've been with
Sarah for 17 years we don't do photos
like that's a timeframe get walking do
with it 17 years morons
done yeah we're not idiots like seven
but 13 years in you know Hollywood
really America that's like 77 [ __ ]
that I like to by 11 but how a normal
the two of them are is like refreshing
you know once you get past all the
butler's and all that zero robot yeah
one robot we have robots but I would
imagine voice lesson here I just wanted
to bring this after sex I'll show you
what about it
Jennifer would you call a little weird I
said Jennifer husbands I wanted that is
a lot for me to learn
are you Alto yes okay I could tell that
already from the song I was like I wish
you would have picked another Keith now
can you just keep it pick it down just a
handset when you get to the song page
100 much so almost sound like that piano
and hit that point and not just clip it
or barely make it and you don't ever
want to have to force it up but
[Music]
[Applause]
yo now you do it I'm a little hard we
just showed our teacher a whole lot
[Applause]
that's I doing dude okay watch it I'll
do that okay and science yoni no piano
you don't need no told selection over to
you in sometimes you can feel if you're
in the right case real fascism yeah
that's a great huh yeah I don't think
that helps for no that's like doing
right now you go geez what I do yeah
dude you're Kobe Bryant and [ __ ] you I
can't do that thanks for highlighting
that I'm nowhere near as you're an
amateur you know how I would do it hit
it boy - your face you know you snap and
they please my grab that isn't
highlighted smash you like take the
pebble from my gosh you you're too slow
my god that is what you see how good
some people are ya
why would one of the could imagine well
I'd like yeah real quick and even like
yeah I love you my son
Neal Brennan you're talking about like
were you just driving home I got damnit
yeah has your little every day that's a
straight competition no I've already
been that girl I'd have been like you
know I'm gonna go ahead and pick another
song what do you got here - well we lost
about the Ed Sheeran thing so that who
that is
yeah and Lady Gaga came to his defense
but I'm thinking this isn't the best way
to get people off of him all right what
do you mean she tweeted something like
you know you shouldn't base people off
their looks and this and that you know
how I find it kinda felt bad looking at
literature and tries away hobo
he's a gazillionaire he's probably 25
yeah I know a lot of ugly guys laughter
they're rich people always say that like
when the only LeBron James off the
finals who gives a [ __ ] here's money man
you have to take all that because they
have money like it's nice they don't do
it no money of you all right
ed sheeran think about you are like in
music especially these days you gotta be
kind of a jack-of-all-trades you have
the looks the you know the clothing the
proper attire everything right but he's
already had that yeah the artist but
that's what I make you think David Bowie
like right right away they're like oh my
god he's so different we welcome him
David Bowie
we're David Bowie hated himself he
wanted to be James Brown he literally
was like every song I make isn't as good
as James Brown like that was his he
hated himself you know I mean it but you
never end it's so talented guys if you
do nothing with music I don't know if
he's experienced l forgot okay no good
she's not a heartthrob but she sings her
ass I'm super attracted to Adele are you
kidding as soon as she opens her mouth
I'm like totally wanna have like will
adopted but not my type but I mean yeah
I hear you Josh of Tucson Treach and uh
wait I actually enjoy giant yeah
Puerto Ricans and Johnny well right
there and God bless he's never losing
human be yet no anyway but that's the
world we live in like it sucks but also
ed Sheeran be bigger than social media
who gives a [ __ ] if people make fun of
your red beard and you're saying awkward
body weight over here they all say it
does probably hurt you know we all why
are you leaving those comments but now
it might be personalities like you guys
talked about alpha personalities with
the chimpanzees earlier and Sigmund
Freud would say there's three major
personality types the Alpha the beta and
the Omega now we all have all three but
one is dominant in each and every human
being on earth and the easiest way to
tell what someone is is through a
compliment or criticism you compliment
the alpha they don't give a [ __ ] they've
decided how they feel long before you
commented Kobe Bryant you suck okay
good right you're the best okay yeah my
actors most artists are the beta
personality they're very susceptible to
criticism you're the best you're the bed
I must be the best you [ __ ] saw okay
don't tweet that it hurts because it
they're very they're much more emotional
they're in tune with a certain are the
Omega
hey you're the best you're the best what
do you want from me hey man you [ __ ]
suck what motivated that comment they're
not emotionally invested they're the
long-term thinker right but ed sheeran
most artists most actors are the beta
personality with a few like omegas like
you can tell George glue
Omega like man you're so good in that
movie what do you need what do you want
cool yeah but he knows something else is
going on and that's the dominant
personality I was artists unfortunately
with social media it sucks being a beta
because you just give bump but part of
what makes him so top it can be the fact
that he's very sense yes yes my pet like
on Instagram all I hear is dude your
gray hair your thousand years old I'm
like yeah bro yeah every day I'm getting
older yeah Oreo campaign I did check
doesn't get smaller because you don't
like my great I feel the way I feel I
know what I mean you can eat bro yeah we
did it we did ridiculousness and he got
hit up like even all these women were
like oh my god you're so hot and I and I
go you do I don't I don't know I didn't
even know about my DMS on Instagram
Instagram remember and I go what
happened you got a bunch of like love
from girls I go what do I have him
before I even check you there don't you
feelings not whining the old man got
young camo one guy goes Callen
Facebook's like a catcher's mitt [ __ ]
off boys I go couch looks like a man
I'll go house venues from K they say me
make you feel better
does not mean that reduce TV show and
they go you want makeup I go yeah and
buying it's not good on the slow turn
the Andy Garcia turn look like a Haley
[ __ ] if I have makeup and you know yeah
you have to have make them I actually
tell whether I'm a go there I I just
never I have I'm so critical of myself
that when somebody I think those
comments are okay really I think most of
them are long-term thinkers behavior
trying to do when you were saying that
Nydia brilliant I think you're dead-on
I didn't it's not my I know it was poor
I don't know I'm sensitive to like I'm
alpha in certain ways and I'm definitely
Omegan other ways yeah we're all I
realized like Jerry Seinfeld who's such
an alpha wing comes to comedy funny you
can can see well I guess you're trying
to get a husband to see Khachatryan hug
yeah no you're doing an interview on the
red carpet she goes it's Cassie that's a
pretty big pop star she's oh my god
you're my friend I'll tell you smaller
what are you doing
I don't wanna hug get out of you know
yes I'm telling you now I don't want a
hug I don't know you're not get out of
here
yeah she's like oh my god like it was an
amazing moment and he goes who the
hell's that ready to go
it's cash she goes yeah that in Paris he
goes what do you do read oh yeah I just
told you I don't want a hug she's like
oh get out here Jerry goes I don't know
you I do not want to my god I would hug
anybody I'm the bomb the war yeah we'd
have leprosy I'd be like bringing in no
two people I mean on the I invited Remy
all ever
I'll keep you there forever I'm just
divorced if I ever got really famous
it'd be a design teacher they know
though in that it's okay like it's okay
you tell with a lot of that because
you've been famous for a long yeah yeah
but I try to treat people with respect
and I always say no in a respect like
what do you mean like what do you say no
to where people are asking for certain
you know types of things in the business
I'm always like a man I appreciate where
you come from no thank you in ordering
in it's gonna hurt some people's
feelings you just have to not worry I've
never learned that over time though oh
yeah I say yes to everything
oh you offered me a movie you must
really like me you must think I'm really
really dude yes but you're also kind of
a tough guy did you ever get in any
spats with paparazzi or anything like
that because I can see you not not being
able to deal with that
anywhere you ever said when I was
younger I definitely did not in a law
not since I had kids then all your
priorities sort of flip and the life
that that I was sort of raised or the
guy was raised to be sort of became
easier to be as far as being send out
and chill but in New York they would get
more aggressive than out here and in
Australia was really the only time it
got bad because like a radio station was
like a $1,000 to ever can tell us where
Sarah and Freddy a living on the island
or and I'm just like what the [ __ ]
and also there's like a million people
outside our house and we were on the
water and the tour boats going by like
the people with binoculars looking in a
bedroom I'm just like what the [ __ ] is
so there were some issues in Australia
but that was you know 15 years do you
want your kids to be in the business no
but if it happened I'm not going to shy
them away from art and drama that's what
they like my daughter likes piano she
likes singing and dancing she like
acting a little bit great artist here
stepping along great and she loves
painting she listened she will make a
solar system right now man we got
styrofoam spheres from Michael's arts
and craft supply store of all different
shapes and sizes and we're three planets
in and my daughter loves me so much
she's gonna let me do Pluto as a planet
yeah about it that's what's up what else
you got turned your French in I see I
think I do it get on social media you
let the trolls win this is what the
trolls want it's all the haters want
gasps we got one off that's ago it's so
negative we got them off yeah it's
better than one and tweet a picture of
your residuals from your records like
that's going to happen am I worried like
yeah look at all this red hair reminds
us Bruce McNall except I'll get guys a
job you suck at Stan a blood Sam stop
for you stay in your lane vehicle sold
out boom okay oh yeah my go-to is always
like I'm sorry you couldn't live up to
the expectations my 90s flick set for
you man I'm sorry some left hand I'm a
ho I'm sorry she looks at you she wishes
it was me your mom looks at your dad she
wishes he was me
I know own you on a multi-generational
Ami's all old very good for any time I
light on a which he fried you do you
talk to your hair control I trow the
Toronto I love it if you want to play
I'll play I made a black guy crying a
basketball court in Harlem just because
he said too much between games about a
dad and I heard that no like oh you're
on going on me you're gonna so I like to
play III well every now and then every
now and then I'll get on them like are
you [ __ ] me and I'll go on a whole
pirate oh I love it dude I know it
sounds like yeah sob acknowledges troll
bro they are but most time I don't have
to Sonya Thomas said something like
sob you suck and I go I'll just wait
I'll let my people they care it and they
get their hole dug it are they worth all
but just [ __ ] destroy the student
makes me know accounts deleted
oh he's usually a private profile I had
a guy I had a guy after I did Rogan and
he goes he's such an arrogant [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just talk the whole time
about yourself and you bring everything
back to yourself you talk about all your
books you've read and I look like me not
yeah and I really just by the way I
wrote back because I had done that I
could kind of done that
the podcast and I went catty and I go
cut dammit you're kind of right about
that I've been thinking about that and
then I got back Daddy an account I went
from hating you to following your
[ __ ] penthouse is David he was a
lot hard to where you're saying it but
he was kind of right at that in that
instance my and I've been thinking about
it anyway and what I acknowledged it
just took his wheels off yeah [ __ ] I'm
far enough
hey bro man let me know when you're
performing hi Robin into that a few
times hey my bad bro my bad my bad or
that can backfire I'm jogging this will
watch when I was fighting I was like it
didn't seem that way man sorry if your
letdown it was [ __ ] you man - are you
trying to do convert me to fan master
back pain happening what I love these I
love the when you get that you're not
funny man you suck I'm like but you're
following me and then there's just no
response
anyway yeah you're so I don't know if I
suck so bad why are you following me
anyway if you're nice I'll talk to you
if you're mean I'll talk to you I don't
care as long as you're entertaining me
I'll maintain the conversation but if
you talk [ __ ] and it's not good I'll
skip that light light because I'll so
you have a ton of opinions on fights and
all these other fights my thing is you
don't have to be offended or you don't
have to take it personal if I don't
agree with your opinion on this I'm okay
well something I got you sooner you can
dodge it for one and oh yeah you can put
your opinion but it just because we
disagree does it mean that I'm this
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] dummy I'm like
insult you just put your opinion man and
then let's have a discussion but when
you offend people then you're out don't
have to block you then your ass I'm like
yo dude I like sushi you might not like
but we still get along why don't you
think about opinion is that there's
nobody who's right or wrong
well our mates in opinion union now if
you're talking about facts that's one
thing but if you're saying like you
think McGregor has a shot yes I don't
think he has any shot in the world right
but now let's add the energy to educate
you on it but I don't well you don't
have to educate I maybe we should just
make a small bet I'm already like 100
okay yeah all right a hundred two grand
in the hole are you
yeah I've a lot of
ready yeah how am i are you really in
and not are they on a win but that it's
going to be would you say what kind of
like not that he's going to win he's
gonna win around how many rounds you
think he wins at least two anything he
goes that he's not getting knocked out
everybody say it goes I don't think it's
not guys join me ran knock out anyone
except the guy who wasn't looking at him
when he fought victory doesn't last guy
um I may have had more lidocaine shots
in his hands than any boxer you know
here like major hamper yeah he's not
knocking that took away your power or
you know you never really had a lot of
plant a little breaking out here ago
Corrales did Ricky was done then and
came - Juno's allow Charmaine Mitchell
yeah power gets charm baby before all
the hand injuries he had a little uh uh
with the horn Pacquiao fight you had
packed how easy I'm not easy but I had
Pacquiao winning the fight why I don't
barely winning like maybe by around
command you all I said the same thing
way McCulloch said if you want to go
[ __ ] get a horn that way that I were
texting or the robbery like I want to
say no problem with boss'll iconic at if
you want to say it was six six I'm fine
with that but the today they around you
gave me live in a gym tonight in the
ninth round yeah he I haven't seen a
woman like that in one round in a long
time that's I don't have not even that's
fair I'm open-minded ten yeah but if you
said you have a five or six six I'm
totally fine with no I watch it I liked
on my ground went I could see horn wins
especially not straightaway it's going
to be [ __ ] closer oh yeah know the
announcers I went you can't listen the
announcers I'm sure not listening now
it's not human fighter who is there
watching it so close Friday knows
fighters are watching it III think it
ought wings color guy like I just came
out of it
I don't know me so but what I went to
bomb out between the fighters and the
announcers that you're too slow you're
too swayed it for one thing one adjey
looking at only when that whole broad
cameras like be team though like that
George I didn't they had that put I
remain oh man a ring apron with Fox
Sports t-shirts on on an ESPN now that
was my issues that we're done will show
the production what everyone should be
talking about if you watch enough boxing
you would watch that production like oh
my god yeah I really respect to Tim
Kennedy or not Tim Kennedy uh Timothy
Bradley he was so bad but respect him I
fighters have a hard time sometimes
communicating fans are tough
I feel no he said argit Argentines or
something like oh no no you a DUI you
never know whose get a win accession to
argentina anything of value but one
thing I can tell you these Japan's I'll
say this people either love or hate or
bad people either love or hate Teddy
Atlas I love Natasha it's sometimes a
generational thing but if his lead
doesn't have a voice that commands
respect if he doesn't have a strong lead
guy he has zero chemistry I love Joe
tessitura but he's such a Salesman that
like you and Teddy say and real stuff
like jet winning I don't know if you
watched the early fights but mostly
George Tom Mosely jr. fought and was
getting kind of exposed and Teddy was
talking about jet lag and he goes look
it affects me I know it affects you Joe
and Joe's like nothing affects me I just
hope I got another I spit like yeah so
sales mini and the whole production
value is just seemed you want to be
invulnerable
we got Terence Crawford coming up and if
it looks crappy like MoMA chanko I
rather ignore that but I like Jerry they
don't get to [ __ ] together
whoever's mean if you're gonna pick a
pick your three to an out to fight any
three from any network to is where you
pick this meal of yeah I think I like
that's Cohen over the active element I
shown that I like Jim Lampley well I
like it I like all the Showtime guys
they like Roy Jones jr. I love Roy I
know Kamala
I don't like Roy so give me a boy oh man
I highly educated boy as far as the
fighters educated he's so biased and I
want you in this is my racing if you if
there's another black fighter in that
[ __ ] ring he will only focus on that
fighter it's an it's a groovy thing like
I watch him every why be clear with it I
watch him a ton that there's a lot of I
don't think a lot of kind of black
fighters the better fighter
very nice in the bicycles they're
usually wooden ah Bernard Hopkins fine
no but I like our Father Gabriel Jones I
think I could Showtime with the [ __ ]
uh what's his name
Paula met Paul Paulie melancholy about
Malignaggi he's amazed Holly does a
great job I notice a job Oh Marley no
you're not
I've never been a moral guy when they
were [ __ ] crazy no why are we w even
though they fired him from WWE that he's
doing wrestling now he's a hero
it's to sale oh he's so good Matt is
that sound like it's been tasting and I
like Roy Jones you're not alone that my
boy MVPs a pro wrestler I've known him
since I worked there he hates Roy Jones
loves more oh we couldn't be we couldn't
be more I don't hate any of that I mean
hey I just think who you connect to yeah
but but with Roy I think he's all I
think he's all right
I think if he didn't have the
credentials of being Roy Jones on the
best of all time he's not sniffing that
mic but that versus an average fighter
Brennan yeah not [ __ ] sniffing Brennan
that career he had is the foundation of
information that he is delivering on
that my fight baby here you go I didn't
what I mean like that's he got it
because he earned it and Emanuel Steward
is really good yeah well I never does it
anymore and this is done in forever
maybe it was one absorb a very good I
love you show times killing it that Jim
Lee you can't really go bad though the
years ago Alan Lee ESPN was a little
rough it was all so new he's got me dead
three million views I don't say that max
told you unlock the match on TV no wow
that man I will see what that not only
that little check it with my house and a
how to draw he's the man turns out not
at all but he's the man if people knew
about Terence Crawford just a great
fight oh you could go what a me you
could make Pam for Pamela's one two he
wants to humiliate you like she beats
you up knocks you out and talks [ __ ]
about you in the post-fight interview he
said did you say whose kid he is my mean
boy I love that kid
me too oh I shouldn't call him kiddo get
mad me up it's really good if you're
boxing as well on ESPN I hope it does
man it should come back they should
provide an exclusive contract boxing
wise with HBO but in the end many words
with first tag yeah does that but his
boxing stuff is exclusive to HP it's
make an employment at HBO let lomachenko
and Crawford know the ESPN I don't think
they have exclusive contracts within
though I think it was a long time ago
you know they signed like a three or
four five do what I think about it yeah
or ESPN bought one of them modified out
but I think they were both up I think
they were both free to go where they
wanted I did get the free box
it's Crawford on people don't realize
that is not a household name but that's
why he spends good to the Rings it's
it's a bigger audience and it was
legitimized for the - man is where your
numbers HP every no but he's a fighter
you want to see him fight blue tears
copper and then I don't want to ever see
him lose so I don't like a loose ball I
know but that my buddy had come up is
tough yeah but he's gonna unify the
belts yeah he's gonna get him I just
can't remember two kids name who's he
fighting was turns out so it's like bow
he's a robust I was like not from
Evergreen about 10 songs no Jackson no
it's only big cardamom in dango bo
diddley in dango Julius Julius mondongo
yeah it's super African that releases no
it said Tom dango is pretty is and I
think in African no liberal in the hole
yeah and on Galindo because it was just
an N I don't think you pronounce it if
it's four belts on the line how crazy is
that
Brian if you got in how heavy is Terence
Crawford he's like what a hundred thirty
five hundred forty pounds are a little
no uh he should be not welterweight
right it's not 147 Callen if you get in
the ring with Terrence Kraft I've got a
ring with with [ __ ] Walter wait what
rule with what if I were so far 119 he's
won people do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to you Manny Pardo Whitaker how long you
last in a ring with with this
professional fighter yeah like that H
second I'm trying to box them yep yeah
I've already tried to do that with guys
who are not even close to that where
they move around with you and hit you
like pop up and you're like - that kind
of an the uppercut you and you go off
guys aren't even proves wait a minute
wait Wayne will come in like hit you and
you're just like what's going on here
man yeah I mean it's way radio chatter
yeah anybody have we really beat
whoredom 70 I don't owe anything to this
guy who rebelled at a silver medal yeah
air separation right that's inflation
right average guy who thinks was looking
I think I got a shot but they don't
understand this in level black I got
North by Sony Ferguson I wasn't mad at
my so I was like ah Freddie
[ __ ] your door Steve
guys got you all did you wrong with him
yeah I know he had 26 percent of the
dart jokes in the history of the yeah I
get it yeah he's getting a break right
you're right you're right you're right
let's do two more here I are boxing so
fool Conor McGregor their first
promotional tour begins in two weeks
these are going to be as entertaining as
the fight
Conner's goodies are going to be
undefeated in these o Connors nowadays
you're not going to think Boyd lost a
step on the mic and I'll be anywhere
hasn't now it's just not as good as
Connery also old and I get my talking
[ __ ] doesn't really work these days
you'd call when I came at the bar so
high oh well is that him holding a doll
yeah no that's a looking at a photo shop
I mean that is compressed Campuzano con
la new york vegas Toronto London London
somewhere else somewhere else important
to boxing
yeah but he's going to chew him up and
spit him out here - he's going to make
people believe and there'd be a lot of
mcgregor money coming in after everybody
like when aggregor wins the spectacle
loses the fight and decision but wins
this win so he's the only thing enemy
talking about asking well then you had
aldo upped because he never has to fight
again I would how many years he fights
do you think he has after this was
controlling me - one night Mad Max he
doesn't have to fight ever again after
this right I have to [ __ ] but in that
belt he tells you to do so they play
ball with them right brilliant you think
he ends up in hallo fight he'll probably
fight to Nate Diaz again for a lot of
money I will say this and I love that's
the fight that be I'd be a most for it
because you're never going to be a
champion again you won't care about that
but I will say this it's and I don't
like criticizing Conor McGregor that
criticizing fighters to be honest but
because I love this guy but you could
say this he never defended a
championship and usually why would you
go to the old-school philosophy and
school philosophy where guys end up
broke with brain trauma I feel you on
that side of it but as far as just the
fighting side of it a lot of I know and
a lot of people think that way but just
that's a generational thing there are
people older than me who respect a
champion that defends at least once and
they're still alive and they still buy
tickets I know and it's a 50
if you kind of I but I'm with Irish I
respect him when I stand for Connors
like I defend or do I jump here make
more money get this belt and jump here
go here or should I go take these
rougher fights on I can make more money
defend my belts I'm just gonna go what
makes make me money and it's gonna
happen from now on they no no no no
there's only not con Connors that he
does he's the fighter of our life to
back he's kind of that golden goose
unicorn I think all porzingis a unicorn
I've seen seven footers the game I'm
shoot him I haven't seen but is the
geology I used once in lifetime type of
athlete so when they're from Ireland B
to go he's not a real fighter because he
didn't offend those Muhammad Ali days
and in that old kinda you know that
let's toss out the window how'd that end
from how I lead how's it end for these
guys with horrible a lot of fighters
love fighting right they they are their
own worst enemy and they don't quit
until therefore we see how that movie
ends on everything I agree unless George
Foreman if Dean George from there found
that [ __ ] grill yeah II screwed yeah
like date a lot of it doesn't end well
for these fighters I really know whether
they make money or not fine
what the what do you want to do have to
find open a gym and hold mitts for these
little Schmucks with sticky fingers for
the rest your life doing private
training right like how's this row to
end so when I see caught in the real job
you say that because you're never
fighter I guess man I've been some tough
guy you were at her and I don't see guys
who were betting I see what they're
doing now but so the the perspective
you're putting on it and I think every
fighter should listen to that is solely
from the business side of things have
the longest greatest future you can
possibly have the old-school philosophy
we'll talk more about this and I'm not
saying I agree with it but I'm just
saying there's a whole generation that
will say you know listen it's about the
sacrifice and yeah you may lose this you
may lose that there's a great line from
eight men out where the spider who works
for I think its outcome not Al Capone
with the the bad guy in the movie and he
says yeah but I was champ I defended I
was champ and the bad guy looks at them
and he goes yesterday's knows yeah but
you know roses generational thing it's
going great when you walk into the bar
and those older guys see you're like oh
man you were chance to you know what
every night
1894 it's like confessing the bondage or
the game in all the sports right Sega's
people it's crossing lines in all the
sports because people are taking an easy
Kevin Durant Durant taking an easier
path he got a lot of heat Yetta I
thought it was really Sox work smarter
not harder
that's what I mean yeah yeah I think I
guess what Mayweather's uncle and dad
both good boxers went through it all
there they taught that kid well I mean
he whether they meant to or not they
told him get hit I've always liked Floyd
Marilyn because I feel like he beat the
game he came out without they could the
crazy head trauma his face looks great
and he's made millions of dollars man I
mean I'll take that any day yeah oh yeah
I know that he's a defensive fighter oh
I know he takes one shot here and there
he doesn't get hit you look silly really
going on yeah he's not exciting to watch
though you know I don't enjoy watching
it yeah he's not I don't want among the
greatest of all time list but know
people who are boxing like purists did
they liked watching his fight there's
some of you mean I could defend like a
baseball fan I love a one to nothing in
here I love a one or nothing boy
mayweather beats Sugar Ray Leonard
probably in his prime at least that's
really to talk about
it's all he's an avid for you it's fun
to debate that stuff but I would
disagree I would think she I think Sugar
Ray would I don't know why because he
generates this fast I think as far as
his defense goes and moving side to side
he would be able to get inside I
employed where other fighters couldn't
but again it's two different generations
it's impossible we can never do it
unless you get an Xbox we did fight
night and we see who the better chance
I'll give you some man che guevara
are we done for a current event that was
very kurz here's that here's my dropping
knowledge very quick I also might know a
guy who might be working these press
tallboy where they big handsome maybe
had some buck facial hair will slick
hair for Showtime really we'll see and
tall and some bronze shoelaces
I know the bra I knew you'd appreciate
like that and my boy Josh brought me
here
Ron laces way though oh they're actually
really what the [ __ ] is going on with
these did you buy us up no you know they
sent me the hook size 12 doesn't you
know you aren't you that walks like a
now have 14 Jesus Christ no even he said
that you were 13 yeah yeah you think I
bought him a pair of shoes
that'd be weird that would be was really
quick you think I do I pay my wage I
would but I came by swung by the mall
and Bob bring on a pair I was like
that's weird I thought about buying
Rogen I was out of that I searched
yesterday by shoe I wait for my when to
converse and you know Rogen always wears
those original Chuck Taylors they just
do pairs like they look original but the
bottoms like all airmax
I was corrected by Rogen those little
gay if I get another it is and it is you
bought me shoes and I appreciate it but
just a lot of friends I got going with
you yeah yeah yeah here's my dropping
knowledge really quickly I thought was
fascinating so when you think that pain
is good for you as in the muscle
soreness you get after you workout Red
Hot Chili Peppers that you put in your
mouth or plastic leg yes or even when
you take a grain alcohol but it's going
to warm you in the winter they
apparently it actually will activate
cannaboids and opioids in your body so
that you will actually create pain
deadening chemicals and the pain will
not be as a placebo effect right so your
body will actually have a physiological
reaction today they tried to test you
still watch Mythbusters I'm sure a very
assertive and here's the best part
they had this dude had a guy and you
were going to get electric shocks and
are going to measure your response and
they had this control guy who was acting
like the electric impulses was so 25%
less painful so the guys actually saw
the guy get shocked before them and
react in it in a way that where it
wasn't that painful they were able to up
that [ __ ] and pitch because the god
of even when they were going and when
they didn't do it with people people got
like what the [ __ ] but when they had a
guy in fun who was pretending to be like
that's crazy it's a little uncomfortable
not bad they were like math doesn't feel
about now they had to control for that
because here's the problem they were
like maybe they don't want to seem like
wimps yeah I just saw somebody before
then macho mez then they decided to
actually test their like the temperature
of the skin their heart rate and their
actual physiological response and how
that actually worked like even the
opioids and stuff and they found that
just by seeing somebody take it and it
act like less less their body relaxed
into it and they did yoga raises so the
point is if you actually think that the
pain is good for you conversely if you
think the pain is bad if you think that
when you work out you're actually
harming your muscles your body will
create chemicals that accentuate the
[ __ ] pain so your brain does have an
effect on whether something is painful
pretty good nah you didn't do the
knowledge voice I did so it was harder
to believe but I believe I got a little
excited we should in photo I should have
brought it down well that's that good
info you get excited yeah lol so how's
my stuff you guys brought brought the
brought the noise man you guys would the
wolf print podcast prints in the world
into the word to the world
all I'm doing I tunes check Levi yeah
honey Dave coming up Josh I took about a
month and I got that offer but I got
Dallas at the end of July at The Improv
July 28th and not on all marketing don't
worry girl and then I'm in in August I'm
in Tacoma and I'm in doing a couple of
casinos and I'm doing Sacramento
Sacramento is probably a big market for
you guys isn't it yes yeah I'm doing
Sacramento to I think second we got our
nice nice man no I got comedy zone
everybody come see me the 20th 21st when
in Charlotte North Carolina and then I
was a great club at Cafe Cleopatra yeah
in
mohile from the 24th to there is to the
top is already the best place relies for
laughs yeah um and then London and
Dublin sold out I know they're they're
giving it 24 hours and they're adding
more shows I think they're trying to add
five more shows they even mentioned they
even mentioned Manchester so get your
minds right and then for the rest of you
Arizona Salt Lake Chicago
baki and toronto a few tickets are left
those are almost sold out t5k calm if
your listeners today at 5:00 p.m.
Pacific the roughhouse Sunday teas are
on sale at tea fightcade calm finally
yes going through these guys podcasters
to the best guys I know he's also got a
best-selling cookbook did you know that
no no I didn't know that but I'm on my
intergalactic comedy tour and I sold out
Venus damn I think more yam Titan one
Dan one day when you guys can get off
this rock you'll see me perform does we
can't open door pause you come anytime
you wanna thank you love you guys are a
lot closer now so it's way he all right
yeah yeah man this is the final kid with
the prince in the wolf we're out